recarus
that shot's incredible that shot's
insane so it took us almost a year to
design that environment what yeah wow it
was a very complex shot you know because
there was nobody on set it was you know
all stun guys that were kind of shown
here and there tell me about how Vagner
was created and the extent of what went
into this character
thanks to noon for sponsoring this video
stick around to find out how you can get
your free new evaluation
[Music]
hey what's up welcome back to another
episode of visual effects artist react
we got a very special guest today Julia
from Rodeo effects joins us on the couch
tell us about why you're here and what
you do well I'm a visual effect
supervisor studying in France in a
little Boutique was a partisan the
production company I work for like music
videos for Janet Jackson Lenny Kravitz I
work with director Mission 3 and moved
in Canada for now seven years where I
joined radio FX like where's some of the
projects that you worked on that we
might have heard about Game of Thrones
Aquaman strangle Things One Division
there's from the loop many many more
you're in town for a very specific
reason because the Emmys are this
weekend Rodeo effects was nominated for
three Emmys I believe yeah so we all
nominated for The Witcher for a
foundation and for surroundings for us
it means it means a lot speaking of
stranger things let's take a look
she's in a vision right now because
vekna is like inside her head and she
managed to kind of like escape and get
into his head a little bit yeah he's
she's basically trapped inside is it so
that's his lair where he's gonna do the
graveyard the way he has you know all
his trophies and all his victims
was created and the extent of what went
into this character actually is a really
nice combination of what we can do in
VFX and what we can do in prosthetic I
think there's a nice collaboration there
all started you know with Michael Mayer
doing like concept of how it's going to
look so we started from that we three
model Victorio getting all the nice
detailing of the vines on his body you
know and then once we get to all the
nice detail in we basically 3D scan uh
Jimmy Bauer or the actor so we made sure
to match his proportion so you know the
armor the same length the legs too even
you know the body so you know it could
fit basically inside the costume then we
were able to ship that and the friction
has been able to print actually the
costume you know they paint all the skin
detail all the veins everything on it I
love that concept because it's like
vekna is a very detailed creature and
started out as a 3D model from concept
and once she got like the actor who's
going to be in the eventual suit you
proportioned it correctly 3D printed all
the pieces painted it all out and it all
just fits perfectly and then it was like
very cool because we kind of truly
scanned vechna back and recreated again
another second time but then matching
exactly the onset one so we could
repression any part of his body if
needed or anything
his entire body is constantly in motion
like I'm looking at his neck tendrils
there like what's the process for
replacing those is it actually a full-on
like track or is it mostly like a 2d
sort of Illusion type thing every shot
is a truly much that's the starting
point you know you have to get like
Pixel Perfect motion of his body and
then you can say Okay I want to keep all
the neck Vines obviously all the moving
Parts you know we're gonna keep the MCG
I'm guessing you guys have basically an
animated texture it's kind of like
moving along the vines is that how
you're doing it yeah that's how we did
it it's basically called the flow map
every Vine has a texture which is red or
green and gives a direction and a speed
so you can control the vine Speed Pro
texture and the vine Direction with the
texture and basically it's only then the
Shader that is animating all the UVS and
make the maps kind of move it's not
something that we do usually in the
effects it's more of a video game
technique exactly a great example you'd
see of something like this in a video
game is like a river of lava for example
you're going along you look at this
River of Love and it looks like it's
flowing in reality the shape of that
river is just there right it's just
polygons they're sitting there it's the
painted textures on top that are moving
along that giving you that impression of
detail now you can just have the painted
part of the texture we could also do
like the bump Maps displacement Maps
it's like all those things can flow
along too which give you the actual
feeling of definition and grit and bumps
on that surface flowing along that's a
great way to get Dynamic motion out of
something without having to like somehow
animate millions of polygons to like
flow and it's looping over itself
basically so you don't have to have like
a gigantic texture you know you can have
a fairly small one and once you reach
the bottom you kind of dissolve back to
the top one and it's kind of an infinite
Loop
so we actually kind of a special
connection to the scene because we
actually had the stunt coordinator
hirokoda came in he showed us how to do
this wire work he talked about his work
on the scene and now we get to talk to
the visual effects supervisor who helped
make all the cool CG monster stuff
happen for the scene so we're getting
the whole picture we're getting
everything here then both hero and you
guys are nominated for Emmys yeah for
the show and I think Euro one did he
yeah
yes hell yeah
it's pretty sick
so you got a long take here yeah you got
people been thrown all around the place
got a big CG monster yeah the take's
still going well it's a very complex
shot you know because there was nobody
on set so it was you know all stun guys
know that were kind of strong even there
and so you guys look at this you're like
okay now much like with Who Framed Roger
Rabbit we need to animate a creature
into the middle of this taking cues from
what's happening in real life and make
it all happen yeah it's a very tricky
process so you have to basically think
okay this guy is moving like that so
what kind of punch did you receive is it
going to be with the feet is going to be
with the arm it's just finding the
proper cues with especially with the
height of the cartoon it's like 90 feet
tall so you're very free but also you
have like a huge constraint so that's
also very interesting you know to try to
find a story it's pretty complex yeah
looks great I noticed there's like
there's good onset Direction like Hopper
there is pointing that spear like up at
the head of the Demi Gorgon he's
imagining it there's no one there like
he's imagining okay I think it's right
here that's you know that's good onset
Direction and knowledge okay things can
be here this time make sure point the
spear in the right point and not you
know somewhere else but of course the
challenge becomes once you have more
than one person interacting with an
imaginary creature everybody imagines
something different that's why you see
somebody running around you know in a
green suit with like a tennis ball on a
stick did you guys do the green suits
like that we had shots with only the
tennis ball no nine feet high we had one
shot with a green suit the one where is
you know eating is dead this one there
was like a green guy you know falling on
his back on the back of the stuntman so
you get the weight you know because
otherwise it's very hard to act you know
without any weight on the back so we
understand that they're both are
connected they are playing together it's
also a very tricky sequence for lighting
you know as you can see everything is
flashing everywhere yeah flashing lights
so if you're not right in 3D space it's
going to show in the lighting because it
is going to be you know under Shadow
it's going to look not look right so you
have to be like super accurate on where
your creature is at
solution for example you know when it's
very close to the to the light near the
door you have to be super accurate yeah
so you know it's basically earring free
space is very close so that's where the
light reacts well we've done that as
well where it's like all right I got an
hdri of the scene that's all I need nope
nope you know proximity to a light
source is incredibly important thanks to
the inverse Square law by being so close
to the light that light has so much more
weight than any of the other lights in
the scene and hence the top of his head
and his neck is so much brighter right
there so you have to be close for it to
react usually we start with a hdri but
this one was like a fully recreated
environment so you can light it for real
even hdri sometimes you know you you
take hdris and then you have to remodel
a bit environment or replace the light
closer so it matches luckily nowadays we
have no lidars for every single shot we
do so we know exactly where we are in 3D
space and we can place the lights you
know right yeah
you know people are like he already made
the Demi Gorgon just use the same 3D
file and it's like well it's not exactly
how it works could you have actually
taken the original 3D model and used it
in the show like from a technical
standpoint yeah it's an iconic character
you know the demogorgon you can't really
touch it but we actually kind of changed
95 of it so an iconic character we can't
touch it at all except we touched it
everywhere exactly yes he's kind of
petal flower kind of mouth you know
obviously you can't touch that but we
change everything else you know like the
length of every of his limbs has been
changed in previous season it was you
know in the dark it was not doing that
much but now we want him to run we want
him to jump how is he going to fight and
we basically change all the size of the
limbs low and the heels and everything
so he could do those actions we took a
lot of references from animals you know
gorilla is kind of running on all falls
and then rising up out there fighting
you know using their feet or using the
hands and so you look at a lot of you
know different creatures to build one
how many teeth does a demi Gorgon have
actually it's the demogorgon it's taking
reference from a turtle actually oh yeah
yeah and they have like awful mouth so
yeah you don't want to your fingers
inside of this mouth huh yeah no thank
you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
possible to build the look of the X
which is kind of the Dome the magic Dome
where I know one day is kind of feel
that invisible wall I'll be honest I
didn't realize the whole Dome was
literally called the hex I always just
thought it was the force field but I
mean it makes sense she's got the entire
town yeah and a bubble of her own magic
it's kind of a magnetic wall and you
know as one division is about TV there's
kind of TV shows from the 50s 60s 70s
everything so we bought actually a few
old CRT TVs and we shot them with a
magnet on screen so we we would like oh
one thing no how does the magnetic field
respond to a magnet and stuff like that
so we do that as a reference and then we
created Tools in new to generate those
patterns so then we were able you know
to add those magnetic fields on the on
the X itself the chromatic aberration
kind of makes it feel like there's a
pixelation effect going on and it
creates that moire effect it all kind of
just ends up adding to this cool sort of
holographic effect exactly
there's many many layers that comes into
creating this this effect you know
there's those Murray then there's the
glitches you know so we're kind of
starting with something a bit more
analog and then the more the show was
progressing then we started to add
digital artifacts and things like that
is that because the show literally
starts off like very analog and then by
the end of it it's modern so so even
though magic is kind of changing knows
interesting yeah
[Music]
it took us almost a year to design that
environment um what yeah wow we started
like very early in flame with a rough CG
model just okay what can we do we know
to create this kind of environment where
you're inside the TV and we also we kind
of redesigned totally the environment
was much more colorful then it was
starting to be a bit close from other
Marvel so you know I don't know if you
recall the Thor Bridge no the Rainbow
Bridge oh yeah yeah we don't want to do
that yeah because it was starting to get
too similar to The Rainbow Bridge at
some point after like month of work I
kind of sent back to Tara the first
version that we didn't know in flame and
I was like maybe that's the idea and she
was like I think that that's it we did
like the 316 you know we tried every ID
that we could and some boys I think the
first one was the greatest one
I think people forget how CG vision is
like this whole freaking helmet thing
the silver helmet yes but we keep the
face as much as we can so we keep the
performance because you know that's what
the actor is here for no you have to
keep him real but then you basically the
whole body you know get replaced
especially in the sequence where it's
basically distracting like that one shot
whereas like his back was starting to
like crack open and flex it's like
there's multiple complex levels of that
you know what is Vision made of you know
we don't really know actually we wanted
to give it like a TV kind of Destruction
you know so it's cables there's like
animation of flight inside of him so
there's kind of little pixels some are
more like hexagons it takes a lot of
layers to make it you know look and feel
complex and not like there's only one
thing going on there's a lot going on
yeah
hey help us help you by subscribing to
us so that you get us subscribe thanks
[Music]
this is probably my favorite sequence
from the entire season like when the
dragons just like lay waste everything
and Daenerys is all like I'm boss now
that shot's incredible that shot's
insane and we combined all those physics
Sims in just one shot it looks so nice
you don't just have the outside of a
boat you have a whole boat built with
all the stuff inside and the props and
everything it's got all the beams in the
right direction so they break the right
way because it's about getting into
variety you want to have no barrels
different type of woods you want to have
you know closes so it looks real if you
only have one type of things that breaks
or destroy then it looks a bit wonky you
know you won't yeah in real life and
there's so many needs it's much more
like much more mess so what comes first
here the breaking of the boat or the
water the breaking of the boat we've
talked about this before where it's like
okay you anime chicken or the egg yes
situation so it's like you have the boat
break but the boat is still on the water
you got the pieces resting on the water
but the water is now influencing the
boat is there like a back and forth
process I think there's like different
layers so you will for example like
break the boat and then you get a seam
of the water what you could do also is
like simulate then the secondary debris
and and then those one will interact
with the water also and interact back so
it's like the boat breaks you get the
big sort of large-scale sim going that's
going to influence the water so then you
simulate all the water and that's going
to influence where all the debris lands
and moves around exactly and then you
can add the splashes and foam on top of
that so it's like kind of goes back and
forth and then it lands on your desk and
you got a composite
yeah pretty much it
the fire is real the fire is practical
actually right and they are very
specific you know on Game of Thrones
they are very specific about the fire so
they shot like you know a flamethrower
element for us to use how do you
composite Fire It's Tricky actually
those EV fires it's very tricky because
it's not like I was saying on the small
frames on on the demigodon that's more
like additive but usually those one you
don't want them to be additive because
the core is actually opaque you don't
see through what do you mean by additive
additive I mean like when you take a
frame you plus it on another frame so
that means it's going to make the image
brighter so it looks always like
semi-transparent if you shoot a real
fire a big one like that you don't see
so it's so dense so fake it becomes kind
of tricky because you're having to like
figure out how to make it look the right
type of opaqueness yeah I've seen this
so many times before where it's like you
get a big explosion element you know a
big Fireball and they just set it up on
top of their footage and hit add and
it's like well the big huge volumetric
Fireball now just kind of looks like a
candle flame yeah it's like a
transparent yeah same for smoke and
there's a lot of on Game of Thrones a
lot of smoke thick black smoke you know
it has to be very opaque you can't plus
that you know it's it needs to be okay
do you guys have a like a stock footage
Library like fire and smoke that like
it's top secret oh yeah we have so good
but no one else gets to see it I think
that's honestly that's one of the things
that amazed me at Rodeo effects you know
when I when I arrived the Practical bank
is insane you know I've shot like a
blood on the face is a puff of smoke
explosion one of the best I saw was I
remember on Aquaman you know the
character is called Mira you know she
kind of jumping out from a plane landing
on on the desert and she's coughing sand
you know are we going to simulate sand
you know to get out of her mouth I don't
know so we we kind of went to the
Practical studio with the guys and it
was sitting exactly the same as the as
the character on screen and it was
basically coughing coughing sand
wow that's the best one that person
definitely knew they're making the real
I love that that's that's great because
you're totally right it's like well we
could create a whole pipeline for this
one shot so that she can simulate some
sand coming out of her mouth it's like
that's very doable but why spend several
weeks in multiple artists doing that
when you can just have a dude dress up
in a black suit
of course then you gotta actually
composite it and whatnot but like that's
also still doable and you get the
realistic motion and motion blur and
dust everything that comes with it I
love that you have like an actual
Department dedicated to assisting the
visual effects you know it always feels
a little bit like a magic trick to me
when you actually figure out how to get
the right practical element made for
your shot it's kind of an art form
that's kind of lost a bit right now I
know you tend to be okay let's do it CG
and brute force it in CG but sometimes
it's not the best way you know the most
complex way is not the best way you know
often
[Music]
the closest face is that the prosthetic
the face you can see for example like
the the cheekbone the mouth is plate
either plate we only painted out pupil
not black people so you're really stuck
to keeping the face yeah realistic yeah
so he lands on him he starts eating his
head but they're both interacting with
the snow on the ground how much of that
snow is from the original plate versus
replaced we added to just know
everywhere so it's a it's like I would
say 50 50 but everything that you see
close-up is definitely see the snow so
you worked on a very low budget Michelle
Grande movie yeah was the first feature
film that we did at partisan so that
first shot where she goes busting
through the actual bookcase there was
that a full like CG bookcase yeah
because I love that shot yeah so you
have to match the plate one to one no
match every books every you know layers
of all so you have layers of wood bricks
concrete so the shot here with Daenerys
is sitting on the back of the Dragon the
dragon's flapping its wings and she's
going from sunlight to shade sunlight to
shade sunlight to shade I've never
noticed that
foreign
s coming out these days it's so hard to
keep up I just can't watch all of it so
I need your help please leave a comment
for some cool visual effects shots that
we should react to on the show thanks
please do my job for me
it finally happened I joined the
high-speed crash Club at Corridor I
broke my shoulder riding a one meal it's
not fun you guys know I've been taking
my health very seriously and because of
my broken shoulder I haven't been able
to do that as much as I want to but
thanks to today's sponsor Noom they've
been giving me all the resources to help
me stay on track during this difficult
time Noom helps you create healthy
habits that make you feel better both
physically and mentally learning not
dieting is what leads to real lasting
change so new helps you learn how your
mind works and the why behind the
decisions you make Noom leverages human
coaches psychology and science to
empower people to take control of their
own health one of the biggest features I
do is your food tracking specifically
your calorie budget so cooking's been
really hard to do with one hand so I've
been using a meal delivery service and
that food delivery service isn't already
in the food tracker but guess what new
makes it super easy to just punch in the
calories you are name the dish so you
can use it for all future times it's
really been helping me stay on top of my
calorie budget even though I'm not
cooking as much as I'd like to so Noom
has an awesome coloring system in the
food tracker which really helps you know
how much you should be eating and what
you're looking at when you're so green
means eat as much as you want that's
usually fruits vegetables yellow kind of
in moderation you know stuff that just
you shouldn't be eating that much of but
it is still healthy for you and then the
orange it's like hey it might be a
dessert it might be able to splurge a
little bit but don't be just eating
orange foods all the time so yeah it's
obvious that Noom helps with the
exercise and the food stuff that's the
physical stuff but Noom really focuses
on Behavioral Science and the mental
part of weight loss they offer exercise
plans quizzes and insights into the root
causes of your eating habits some of the
themes they teach in these lessons are
breaking the behavior chain crushing
your thought distortions improving your
mental health start eating less dense
and like unprocessed in your diet these
are all things that they break down in
detail and as always my girl Jennifer
she's my personal new coach I even told
her about my broken shoulder recently
and she gave me a bunch of resources I'm
just like things you can do to stay
active different recipes that are easy
to make it's great to have a one-on-one
person on the other side of the line for
any questions while you're going through
this new Journey so if you're like me
and you're looking for the next step to
make long-lasting change in your health
journey I highly recommend joining new
so go to noon.com corridorcrew or click
the link in the description below to get
your free new evaluation today and
please reach out to me I love seeing all
your feedback it's very motivating to
hear that you guys are benefiting from
this program it just motivates me more
let's keep motivating each other and
with that let's get back to the react
episode
man that was so cool honestly honestly
my favorite part about what we looked at
today were all the great s you know one
of my favorite things watching a
breakdowns and I guess you can find that
on the rodeo effects website their
Instagram Julian thank you so much for
joining us today it was a pleasure
having you thanks for having me it was a
real pleasure to meet you guys a huge
congrats on Rodeo FX and you guys being
nominated for an Emmy for all the work
that you guys did that's so cool I'm
only a little bit jealous that you're
gonna get to go hang out at the Emmys
and I'm just like I mean I guess I can't
complain I have it all right we will see
you next Saturday actually we'll see you
tomorrow because we also upload videos
on Sunday and they're always super cool
you should just you know just stick
around for like 24 hours and then
refresh the page
all right bye